there was one study that was conducted
around the 2013 Boston Marathon bombings
the team of researchers looked at two
groups of people the first group of
people were those who watched six or
more hours of news coverage about the
bombings and the second group of people
were runners in the actual marathon and
what the team of researchers found was
those who watched six or more hours of
news coverage about the bombings were
more likely to develop post-traumatic
stress disorder and they experienced a
higher level of chronic stress than
those who were in the marathon and
personally affected by it
you have written two books two
best-selling books on productivity yeah
and now you're writing a book about
calmness and how to calm your mind what
what gets you interested in working out
how to calm your mind yeah this book was
honestly a lot tougher to write than the
other two uh you know we were chatting
before there are no productivity
emergencies out there maybe maybe
there's a couple that I haven't heard of
uh but if you're a doctor there are
medical emergencies but there aren't
productivity emergencies uh and it was
really kind of an urgency though in my
own life that led me to write this this
book called how to calm your mind I was
not in a good place a few years ago I
was anxious I was burnt out and this all
culminated a lot of this was happening
beneath the the depths of my awareness
at the time and this all Crescendo on
stage for me I was on stage in front of
about 100 people uh giving a talk on
productivity of course and I noticed
when I got up on the stage that beads of
sweat started to form on the back of my
neck I felt as though I was struggling
to get my words out like my tongue had
to dance to around a bunch of marbles
inside my mouth and I I started just
stammering and stumbling on my every
word and I realized up there you know
right when I wanted to kind of flee the
stage I was having an anxiety attack in
front of this audience and I had taken
on too much stress I had taken on just
too many commitments in my work and in
my life I had too much chronic stress
and found myself kind of picking up the
pieces after this episode
where I realized I was burnt out I was
anxious and I had been investing in
self-care quite a bit up to that point
and that's kind of what baffled me at
the time and got me to look at the
research out there and talk to experts
to try to honestly desperately try to
solve this in my own life I hadn't
really thought about a book at the time
because you know when you're in kind of
an emergency like that that's the last
thing on your mind you're just trying to
oh you're just trying to get through but
uh yeah that's that's kind of how this
journey began was there any shame
associated with being the productivity
guy who also kind of doesn't seem to be
holding it together while supposedly
talking about his
uh Mastermind topic yeah yeah definitely
you know you I I thought you know I
think a big part of that was we we tend
to buy into these narratives that other
people tell us about ourselves uh and
that was a big part of my own story is
buying into this story that people had
shared in intros and bios and in blurbs
leading up to that point where honestly
and this sounds kind of ridiculous
looking back on it but I think a big
part of me thought that I was
unstoppably productive that there were
really no limits to how much I could get
done as if the endorsements were were
true you know that that I was kind of
Unstoppable or this superhuman I I don't
know I I don't even want to regurgitate
the the different words that people use
to to describe my work but of course you
know we all have these normal human
boundaries and I think that was kind of
an internal Reckoning that I had to go
through that there was this story that I
had told myself about myself that I'd
constructed my identity out of this
super humanly productive kind of
narrative and it just wasn't true
because
of course it's not true it's it's the
most obvious thing in the world we all
have normal limits so yeah this I love
the question yeah there definitely was
shame yeah I uh I think reflecting on
Jordan Peterson over the last couple of
years is a good example a psychiatrist
that was telling everybody to carry a
burden and be honest and truthful and so
on and so forth yeah people
um his detractors online took a great
amount of joy in pointing out the fact
that he was the person that was addicted
to benzodiazepines for a good while he
was the guy that was on antidepressants
he was the psychiatrist that couldn't
get stuff to work yeah you think yeah it
is
the expectation adds another layer of
um guilt and shame and
um
perspective that isn't helpful on top of
already your own expectations of
yourself
yeah and we already construct our our
self-identities on Shaky Ground you know
we construct them on top of our success
at work for example but when that
success goes away we we feel like we're
kind of losing a part of who we are and
you're so right there there is that
expectation I think it comes with
expertise uh and I see a lot of
Happiness experts out there who go
through periods of depression I see a
lot of experts on meditation who fall
off the way I see a lot of
lazyproductivity experts out there too
myself included it's what drives me to
explore these subjects of productivity
uh and I think we kind of need that
contrast in a way to realize how well
the best strategies work not only for us
but for other people
yeah what have you come to learn about
burnout then it seems like this was a
period of extreme burnout for you uh
what what did you not know before that
now seems completely obvious yeah it's
what burnout even is you know you know I
think you've had folks on the podcast
who've chatted about burnout but in my
mind I thought it was just burnt out you
know burnout is exhaustion right if
we're completely wiped we're completely
depleted we're burnt out but realizing
that exhaustion is just a third of the
picture of burnout was one of the most
surprising things that I myself
discovered and it explained a lot of how
I was feeling at the time exhaustion is
a core component of burnout but it's
only a third of the burnout equation as
defined by researchers like Christina
maslak and the World Health Organization
we need to be exhausted right that
feeling of being just totally depleted
but we also need to feel cynical we need
to feel feel as though there is this
negative attitude just that pervades
everything that we do that's the second
attribute of burnout and the third is
unproductive right we need to feel as
though what we're doing doesn't make a
difference and like we have nothing left
in the tank to make a difference with
who we are and it's the Confluence of
those three ingredients exhaustion
cynicism and inefficacy that produces
full-blown burnout phenomenon that's
caused by one thing and one thing only
and that's chronic stress any source of
stress we Face repeatedly is something
that can cause burnout and the more
sources of chronic stress some of them
are obvious right Financial concerns
just you know marital stress all these
different sources that we can see but a
lot of it's hidden right the threatening
information that we choose to pay
attention to in social media on the news
simply because it's familiar can lead us
to that point point of burnout but also
the factors of our work that contribute
to a full-blown burnout phenomenon there
are six of them in fact and so the more
in alignment we are with these six
factors the more engaged we become and
the less burnt out we become but these
six areas of our work are also the the
Petri dishes that the chronic stress of
our work can incubate inside of and so
those are how much work we have on our
plate whether we're rewarded fairly and
that's that goes to money that goes to
social rewards that goes to being
recognized for the contributions that we
make control is a third one so whether
or not we feel we have control over when
where and how we do our work community
so whether we feel connected with people
around us the less Community we have the
more likely we are to burn out fairness
we need to be treated fairly and values
so whether we feel as though we can
manifest our values through our actions
at work and when we do that we feel like
there's meaning behind what we're doing
because we can observe our behavior and
connect those with who we truly are but
when we don't value the work that we do
or we don't have that deeper connection
we're out of alignment and we're more
likely to burn out and so you know just
in case people don't read the book no
pressure obviously but I want to kind of
share those six factors charting how
well you're doing in those six areas
over time workload control reward
Community fairness and values and
noticing that you're on the Stepping
Stones to that full-blown burnout
phenomenon even if you're cynical and
not exhausted or even if you feel
profoundly unproductive but you have
more than enough energy these three
attributes can serve as kind of Stepping
Stones to a full-blown burnout
phenomenon that's interesting what are
some of the ways that people can better
notice what's going on and self-regulate
because these are emotions they're going
on inside of our head there is no
external scoreboard that's going to tell
us where we're at with our cynicism or
energy or productivity uh what are some
of the ways people can self-regulate uh
one of my favorite ways and I'd be lying
if I said I did this every week or even
every month but since going through that
burnout I do this every probably three
or four months or so or whenever I'm
feeling exhausted or wiped or I have
that kind of dread on Sunday that I have
to work again the following morning that
that's kind of my cue to to pick up
where I left off here and I just have a
spreadsheet so I write how well I'm
doing in each of these six areas out of
ten and it's pretty informal I haven't
seen a ton of evidence uh behind this
particular tactic but it does feed into
the wealth of evidence out there
especially uh you know workload is one
to pay a particular mind to because
that's often one of the primary
contributors to burnout and it's in fact
in clinical settings it's the first
thing that they get you to look at uh
and you know they say okay can you cut
back on workload because that really
Cuts back on how much burnout you have
but just charting how well you're doing
in the six areas can really make a
profound difference and you can notice
the trend line over time so if you
notice that sense you know covet for
example your line has been ticking
upwards and along that upward tick
you're starting to feel more tired and
cynical and unproductive that's probably
why
you mentioned all of the different
contributing factors that come from work
there are two broad cohorts of people
right one are employed and have a boss
and have a relatively limited amount of
control over the work that they do and
another one would be someone that's
self-employed and it is their own boss
is there anything that you've come to
believe about the interesting
distinction between the two how they
should regulate their burnout and their
workload and the social uh respect that
they get from the work that they do is
there's something unique about those two
cohorts yeah the the fascinating thing
is it really does vary and so you know
for advice on calm anxiety productivity
even uh one one thing I really believe
is we have to take the advice that works
for us and leave the rest uh there is no
advice that works universally well for
and even if there are these six
universal factors uh control is is the
fascinating one I find you know
especially with regard to how much
autonomy we have in our work
um you know we we may not have control
over what we work on but in ideal
circumstances regardless of whether we
work for somebody else or ourselves we
often have control of when we work on
something and how we execute a gut I you
know I hope I hope that's the case with
us because so many of us do knowledge
work for a living that takes advantage
of our unique mind and perspective and
skills and expertise experience and so
we should fight for control however we
can and you know one thing that I found
fascinating in looking at the research
as well is often burnout it's our
responsibility to deal with when we go
through an episode of burnout but it's
usually not our fault you know it's kind
of the the fault of whoever creates the
conditions with where we work and so if
you're a manager that that's something I
would highlight in addition to the to
this if you're a manager who has had
employees that have burnt out that
should be your tripwire that should be
your you know your alarm Bell that's
something in the workplace that you're
cultivating for people is fundamentally
uh broken and toxic and the the key
there I think is realizing that it
burnout is you know not being burnt out
is not really a luxury we need to not we
need to be past the point of not burnt
out burnout exists on a spectrum uh one
side is burnt out where we're exhausted
we're cynical we're unproductive and on
the other side we're fired up we have
this energy beneath what we do we're
engaged we're uh we're productive we're
making a contribution burnout is on one
side and engagement is on the other side
of this spectrum in terms of how much
energy we have and so it's worth
fighting to have those conditions if you
don't have necessarily have that
autonomy uh where you can control uh
what where how you work on things and if
you're a manager man check the
environment you're creating if you find
that people have these conditions
because they're not just burnt out their
minds aren't just suffering uh their
productivity is as well in terms of
Engagement why not just push yourself
until you burn out relapse and then go
again why is that not an acceptable
solution
well because it's a a recipe for misery
you know and I think it comes down to
what you value too you know and there's
nothing wrong with valuing
accomplishment you know accomplishment
does lead us to savor Our Lives less
that was another interesting field of
research is the the subject of savoring
which is just the process of enjoying uh
experiences because just because we
experience something positive does not
mean that we'll enjoy it you know I'm
drinking this amazing delicious cup of
of Jasmine green I think uh you know
just like last episode I remember
drinking a little green tea with you man
um and just because I simply on this
amazing green tea does not mean that I
will enjoy the experience just because
we experience something positive doesn't
mean we'll internalize it and generate
positive emotions from it and the more
we actually strive to accomplish the
less likely we are to savor and enjoy
our lives and in luxury create in in the
positive experiences that comprise our
day and so if you value accomplishment
you know there's nothing wrong with
having some hustle as long as you have a
Direction but I think so much of the
advice out there that you know we should
hustle until we have this empty tank
assumes that accomplishment is the only
thing that is worth valuing and really
values came up a lot in this uh Journey
that I embarked on we need to manifest
our values through our daily actions and
I glossed over this you know couple
paragraphs ago and when we were chatting
but
you know when we can observe ourselves
manifesting our values through our
actions that's the process through which
meaning is made right if we value
kindness and we can express that through
volunteering we're going to have a more
meaningful experience than somebody who
doesn't value kindness because we can
observe ourselves going through that
process if we value service if we value
connection and we can observe ourselves
manifesting those things we're going to
feel like we're making a bigger
difference maybe even a bigger
difference than we actually are a lot of
the times but it really does come down
to values and realizing that there is a
complexity of values that lies at the
core of who we are that we deserve to
express in how we act accomplishment
being maybe one of them but by God
hopefully not the only one you would
hope so I mean one of the interesting
things I've learned this year is people
for
in the modern world a lot of people are
very happy to give up the thing that
they want in order to achieve the thing
which is supposed to get it so people
will give up happiness in order to
achieve success in the hopes that their
success will afford them happiness yeah
I'm sure you know about the the story of
the American businessman and the the
fishermen that's out on the water and he
says you know if you build this up as a
business then you would be able to sell
more and maybe you'd be able to employ a
bunch of people and then after a while
you'd be able to run a factory and you'd
have all of these fish and he said well
why and he said well if you do all of
that then you'd be able to spend all of
your day fishing in a boat on your own
you go well that's my life already and I
do wonder how much over complication
comes from people
um trying to go the long way around
in order to achieve happiness and I
think that success is one of the easy
traps that that gets into it is so true
yeah exactly and and so much of the
modern world it tells us what we need to
do to be happy like accomplish more
generate more status but the the last
place we should be looking for happiness
is the modern world I mean look around
the modern world is not happy people
can't Savor experiences like they used
to people Rush past the most beautiful
moments of their life right time with
family time with these deep experiences
time that they could otherwise connect
with what they value to distract
themselves and to pursue greater
accomplishment things that pull us out
of whatever it is that we're
experiencing and whomever it is that
we're with and it's this it's this
disconnect between what we usually value
most deeply on this personal level and
what the world around us values on this
cultural level and every single one of
us has a disconnect in that regard no
not one of us unless we never reflect on
what we value or who we are or what our
mission is what our purpose is
unless we never reflect yeah if we never
reflect we'll have perfect alignment to
our culture and then we'll become even
more miserable
yeah
what did you learn about burnout from a
either a neuroscience or a evolutionary
theory perspective I mean why would
burnout be an Adaptive response and
what's going on inside of the brain and
body when we uh hit it yeah so our body
it turns out gets used to whatever
stress we provide us with and it gets so
used to it sometimes that it gets fed up
with having to go through the whole
rigmarole of generating that stress
response uh you know to that Spike of
cortisol levels our pupils dilating our
heart rate elevating to to mobilize to
face down a threat which was usually
physical those these days were just you
know sitting in front of our email
clients stewing over one negative
message and so burnout on this
biological level is a refusal of our
body to generate a stress response in
response is something that our our
ancient mind usually perceives as a
threatening situation and I use the
example of measuring my own cortisol
levels in the book so I had uh the this
uh it was a saliva cortisol test so it's
not as reliable as a blood cortisol test
but I had my levels measured when I was
going through this period of burnout
just for sheer curiosity's sake and
there's kind of the normal range of
cortisol cortisol response to a
threatening situation cortisol of course
being a primary stress hormone and our
cortisol levels usually spike in the
morning which is good right because
that's what mobilizes us to to do the
day to get out of bed to to take on
whatever the day might offer us and then
they kind of Trail off as our energy
goes down throughout the day and I
noticed when my own levels came back
that they had basically flatlined there
was no cortisol spike in the morning
there was no kind of uh rise in the
middle of the day and it just kind of
flatlined all day long and so in other
words regardless of the stressful
situation that we experience when we're
burnt out we can't generate the the
mental resources to overcome whatever
stressful situation is presented to us
and that's where that feeling of
exhaustion cynicism uh being
unproductive comes from some stress is
good
right stress provides us with meaning if
you removed all the stressful episodes
from your life you'd also remove all the
meaning from your life you'd remove the
weddings the anniversaries you'd remove
the weird Thanksgiving meals with family
you'd remove the the most challenging
moments of your life too but too much
stress does deplete this capacity for a
stress response over time and that
that's what the research shows on the
subject of burnout is burnout is the
refusal of our body and our mind to
mobilize to a stressful situation it's
when our stress response flat lines and
it is the ultimate manifestation of
chronic stress in our work and in our
life that usually comes from those six
areas so it's kind of like your body
just giving up and saying yeah I'm
carrying too heavy of a weight I'm not
going to respond to the stress anymore
and my solution for this is to
completely kill all all motivation to
make you feel
um doubtful about the future and to dial
down your ability to be productive
exactly it's not working anyway so why
keep generating it let's say that
there's someone listening now we're
coming toward the back end of the uh um
lots of people will have worked very
very hard or maybe we're going into the
new year and you just think God all of
these things that Chris is talking about
it feels like that's me like just taking
off all of the different elements and
maladies that you've described how
should somebody that is currently
dealing with burnout get out the other
side of it
yeah burnout is a fascinating
phenomenon for that reason and there's
so much that influences how burnt out we
are but I think keeping kind of an eye
on the ball that chronic stress is what
causes that phenomenon of burnout uh
chronic stress is you know we've all
heard the term but really dissecting the
sources of chronic stress we face in our
life so we have two kinds of stress that
we face all day long day in day out
every single day there's acute stress
which is the once-off moment it's you
know the traffic jam on the way to the
airport it's the once-off argument with
your spouse that's a huge pain to get
through and it it's what forces you to
grow but it's The Chronic stresses the
no good very bad kind of stress that we
Face repeatedly instead of the argument
with our spouse it's the a reconcilable
feelings we have when we see their dumb
stupid face uh when we you know instead
of the traffic jam it's the it's the
traffic we encounter every day in rush
hour on our way to the office that's
like an hour and a half on the other
side of town really understanding
the stress that exists in your life is
the recipe for overcoming uh this
burnout phenomenon so first of all you
know dissect those six areas where the
chronic stressed because that that's
where you should Spotlight those are the
kind of Petri dishes in our work that
this stress tends to metastasize and and
grow and expand to to fit a level that
we don't really have the capacity to
cope with but then we have all the
stress that's hidden in our life uh all
throughout our days so anything
threatening
that you pay attention to over the
course of the day is likely a source of
hidden chronic stress in your life you
know there was uh one study that was
conducted around the uh 2013 Boston
Marathon bombings and the team of
researchers looked at two groups of
people uh the first group of people were
those who watched six or more hours of
news coverage about the bombings and the
second group of people were runners in
the actual marathon and what the team of
researchers found was those who watched
six or more hours of news coverage about
the bombings were more likely to develop
post-traumatic stress disorder and they
experienced a higher level of chronic
stress than those who were in the
marathon and personally affected by it
and so
then
that's shocking to me you know
encountering studies and statistics are
usually not that motivating they usually
don't drive us to action but that one
was kind of a holy [ __ ] moment uh is
this really how my mind interprets the
news uh so I compartmentalized the news
checking to just one newspaper each and
every day I compartmentalized social
media time to uh one block within the
middle of the workday so I could just
get it done and get on with my life uh
anything else that I want I eliminated
one threatening not not threatening but
one toxic relationship uh in my life
over the course of this project to great
success it kind of freed up a lot of
mental and emotional bandwidth and so
really dissecting the chronics list it
if you want list every source of stress
you face over the course of the day
divide it into chronic stress and acute
stress and under chronic stress do mind
the stuff that's hidden because all this
stuff can lead us away from calm and
towards anxiety as well not just this
burnout okay so somebody has realized
wow I'm watching way too much of the
Muse and the yeah the ccp's algorithm on
Tick Tock is making me feel like I want
to throw myself out a window seriously
yeah all the rest of it
um but they're still stuck in this
particular embodied state is there
anything that you've found as you're in
Burnout this is a an ejector button that
you can push which is going to help to
actually really reinvigorate you
um if you are feeling cynical
unproductive low in energy demotivated
um what were the quickest ways that you
found to get yourself back from that
yeah so one simple way is to Define
productivity hours every single day
burnout has traditionally been defined
as a workplace phenomenon and that's not
to say that it still is we have stress
that comes in from every direction of
our life right now uh from our personal
lives to our work lives but defining
boundaries around that pursuit of
productivity at work is one of the most
powerful strategies that I personally
like to deploy every single day so at
the start of the day I'll choose when I
start to care about productivity and
I'll Define when I'll stop caring about
productivity these days it's around ten
to six and so I have the mornings for
just starting things off slow and
deliberately and carving out a bit of
time for meditation and reading and just
having this slow morning that can lead
to this calm deliberate day and then
having this wind down ritual at the end
of the work day where I can choose to no
longer care about accomplishment and so
you know that goes back to that
accomplishment mindset as well is when
we're in this acquisition mentality this
acquisition mentality leads us away from
this presence is calm in our life and so
the more we focus on acquiring the less
we actually enjoy ourselves and so this
these productivity hours can kind of
serve that double purpose of limiting
your workload gaining more control over
your day having that reward at the end
of the day so even if these external
circumstances aren't put around your the
boundaries of your work by somebody else
you can choose to to do this yourself
and if you're not paid to be on call
don't be on call if you're not paid to
be connected in the evenings don't
connect in the evenings and I think that
the irony of this is it's often by
stepping back that we become more
productive you know it's by stepping
back we actually recharge we can
actually spend more time in the analog
world and not just stare at screens all
day long the the most calming energizing
parts of our life are found in the
analog not in the digital we can
actually step back from this big source
of chronic stress in our life and turn
to the hopefully more acute sources of
chronic stress and meaningful or not a
chronic acute stress in our personal
lives and so defining boundaries around
that practice is critical
that bleed out from a period of
productivity into the laptop is still
open I'm still working away I've got
something in the back of my mind that
needs to be done it's just it permeates
everything right the entire Fabric in
your life is ambiently anxious because
there is always the option to do work
you could always be doing work yeah
everybody could always be
Scouting For more clients or networking
more effectively or spending time
building up their LinkedIn profile or
whatever it is right researching the
next piece of content that they're going
to write and yes the
I read a while ago that the ancient
Greek word for work was translated as
not at Play
which was interesting because the set
point that we see now is that play is an
aberration and work is the set yeah
previously it was the other way around
that play is the set point and work was
the aberration what was the thing you
had to get done and I always like
thinking about that in relation it might
be total bollocks but I always like
thinking about it as a concept
um
when it comes to this sort of you've
mentioned anxiety a couple of times that
what's the difference in your mind or
relationship between burnout anxiety
calm productivity how do all of those
things fit together oh so much comes to
mind man that's a blank check of a
question it's uh I I find the
relationship between these things
absolutely fascinating and you know this
was and maybe I'm weird in this way like
I used to see uh the therapist I saw I
started seeing her when there's I didn't
perceive anything wrong in my life or in
my mind I was just curious to to
untangle what was happening up up there
in my head and this is this kind of has
a similar vibe to me where just sheer
curiosity uh pulled me forward into this
journey but first of all between calm
and anxiety so this was one of the more
fascinating uh elements that I uncovered
on this journey because I was never
really compelled by calm uh the only
time I've really ever uh felt the need
to find calm in my life is when I've
become anxious uh when I've wanted just
that anxiety to go away and in my head
anxiety was speaking of spectrums uh
anxiety was always the spectrum that
went from zero anxiety all the way to
this intolerable level of anxiety but
the research shows that anxiety and calm
are opposite ends of the same Spectrum
where we relate to our thoughts either
in a positive way or a negative way and
our mind is either agitated or it is
still and so those two variables
determine where we are are on the
Spectrum but what this means is that we
can go past the point of no anxiety
and travel further down on this road to
calm and continue to Garner a lot of the
benefits that a less anxious mind has
and one of those uh to hit another
keyword in the question is productivity
and this product this relationship
between anxiety calm and productivity is
fascinating because if I asked you you
know
let's say you have to give a
presentation to a thousand people in 15
minutes and you know all all that is on
your mind is this presentation of course
because it's 15 minutes from now you
want to do a good job and if I asked you
in that same moment you know 15 minutes
before this talk hey you mind reading
this article that I wrote and giving me
feedback or hey do you mind you know
digesting and summarizing this journal
article or do you mind you know doing
any bit of knowledge work by God you'd
have a a very challenging time doing it
and this is the effect fact that anxiety
has on our cognitive performance when we
work with an anxious mind
it's for this reason that our work takes
longer uh you know I I break down how
about eight hours of real actual work
takes us about 10 hours because anxiety
actually reduces our cognitive capacity
this goes back to our last conversation
on this idea of our working memory
capacity our attentional space this
mental scratch that pad that we use to
process whatever it is that we're doing
in the moment anxiety shrinks our
working memory capacity by about 20
percent so might not sound like a lot
but when our work takes 20 percent
longer eight hours of work takes around
10 hours especially when you add in the
other factors that lead us to even a
greater decline in productivity we
become more aware of the threats that
are surrounded by us we become more
susceptible to distraction when we're in
an anxious State our mind is more
stimulated again a higher level of
mental activity and the more stimulated
our mind is the more we wish to keep it
at that State and so we're more
susceptible to
dopaminergic distraction any distraction
that releases a hit of dopamine in our
mind which is also uh considered when
you look at the research to be an enemy
of presence and calm not completely it's
more complex than that I found digging
through these ideas but it's fascinating
just how much of a cognitive limiter
anxiety is but you look at people who
are calm Under Pressure that calmness
that we can cultivate in our life
um
it is a Wellspring that lives at the
heart of what makes us productive and
what makes life uh meaningful it leads
us to presence it leads us to focus it
leads us to Be steady and have this
attention and this confidence that
regardless of what happens around us we
are where we need to be we're doing what
we need to be doing and we can focus on
it without our anxious mind tugging at
our thoughts and I actually think eight
hours of work takes far far longer than
10 hours and when you work with an
anxious mind and if you notice you know
that you have less time than before you
have less attention than before you know
the anxiety is it's kind of a hidden
factor that influences our productivity
it's one we never think about but it's
one that influences us all all day long
we might not have that same
effect that we do before we're going on
stage but we have a similar effect
that limits our cognitive performance
only all day long when we're working
with this anxious mind isn't there
something funny about the fact that most
people who are pushing very hot who are
type A go getters are creating an
environment in which the mind is less
productive in service of being more
productive yeah push myself I'm going to
continue to go harder but what you're
actually doing is applying more break
whilst you apply more accelerator at the
same time exactly even on a neurological
level if you look at the networks of our
brain that are activated when we're in
this acquisition mentality versus when
we're present with something so presence
you know it sounds like a hippie dippy
term but presence is just being able to
focus on what you're doing presence is
the process through which we actually
become more productive and if you look
at the networks of our brain that are
activated when we're in an acquisition
mentality versus focused on some thing
in the here and now they're
anti-correlated with one another so the
acquisition mentality is primarily
structured on top of the neurochemical
dopamine so much so that a lot of
researchers refer to dopamine dopamine
as the molecule of more whether it's
more accomplishment or more stimulation
whereas networks of presence are
centered around serotonin oxytocin which
leads us to to feel proud and connected
and happy with what we're doing and it's
fascinating how we
you know I feel the extra drive that a
lot of people have compensates for this
fact that they have less energy in a lot
of cases simply because they spend more
time you know trying to Manifest this
value of accomplishment all day long but
because of that countervailing Force
it's probably a wash you know in terms
of just how much further you get you
might as well enjoy things while you're
doing them well you might as well become
more present in what you're doing and
you know this is I think the goes back
to my philosophy of productivity is
productivity advice exists to
optimize the the benefits and the
contributions of our work you know we
should feel as though our work is making
more of a difference and we do when
we're more present
I wonder if an element of this is to do
with laziness as well that if you are
working more
for longer periods of time you actually
can afford to be less focused you can
apply less effort to it and running
twice the distance at half the speed is
significantly easier than running half
the distance at twice the speed yeah and
this goes back to that whole idea of
productivity hours and it seems like
such a simplistic tactic but I think one
of the reasons it works so well is it
has sort of a deadline effect uh and so
if you have a full week's worth of work
in front of you and it's Monday and
somebody says to you hey you want this
all expenses paid uh trip to Australia
but it leaves on Wednesday
you'll probably find a way to accomplish
all of that week's worth of work between
Monday and Tuesday maybe Wednesday
depending on how this analogy is
structured and you'll probably find a
way because of this deadline effect to
accomplish it all and it's just the
deadline effect when we have less time
for something that time limiter forces
us to expend more energy over that
shorter distance of time so we can get
the thing accomplished and we should
always have a bit of time pressure
behind what we're doing no time pressure
is an episode for laziness it's a it's a
sign that our work is expanding to fit
how much time we have available for its
completion which is often called
Parkinson's law you know our work will
expand you know it's it's this it's this
thing we have to compress so if you
don't feel as though you always have a
bit of time pressure not too much too
much creates yet another source of
chronic stress when our workload
eclipses our capacity to get it done in
a major way that's a contributor to
burnout it's contribute to to anxiety as
well but we should always there is this
Goldilocks zone of time pressure and if
you don't have it most of the time
you're probably working too many hours
let's say that there's someone listening
who is a type a go-getter they like the
idea of accomplishments they like the
idea of achieving and being in
acquisition mode yeah and they don't
like the idea of leaving a lot on the
table but they also don't like the idea
of being burned out and this ambient
anxiety and the stress and neurosis and
all that yeah what have you come to
believe about the balance between not
leaving a lot on the table about
maximizing what you can achieve about
actually going out there and getting it
and getting after it whilst having this
more holistic view of the self and of
work is it possible for these two things
to exist side by side yeah and so much
of this uh Journey for me was finding
that balance you know I want to make a
big contribution through the work that I
do and I also don't want to be miserable
and I also don't want to be anxious and
I want to enjoy the things that I create
and a big
Discovery over this journey for me was
realizing that you know this connection
between dopamine which leads to mental
stimulation and anxiety and
accomplishment and how I've come to see
things and this is a way that I like to
find balance in my own days is every
single thing we tend to over the course
of the day
exists at a different height of
stimulation and so a different height of
mental stimulation depending on how much
dopamine something releases and so the
size of the dopamine hit we get it's it
fluctuates based on genetics it
fluctuates based on how much something
directly affects our life but you can
kind of divide by you know the same
amount for things online because most
things online don't directly affect our
life that we see what really differs in
the things we encounter online is the
relative novelty of the information uh
novelty if something is surprised sizing
it releases a far greater dopamine hit
than something that isn't and so you
know online we can kind of sort things
by novelty but every single thing we
tend to over the course of the day
release is a varying level of of
dopamine and so it exists at a different
height of stimulation a different
altitude so hard drug use would be at
the very top which leads to a huge
dopamine Surge and then a plummet
afterward beneath that it might be
social media it might be the the super
stimuli we tend to online these you know
highly exaggerated versions of things
that were by default our mind is wired
to Crave and enjoy so pornography is a
great example of this too this highly
artificial thing that our brain is wired
to Crave these exist in the analog world
too so take out anything on most things
on ubereats this is my Escape of choice
um it is you know that stuff is high
it's a super stimuli it's highly
dopaminergic so that exists at a higher
height of stimulation but then you start
working downwards in these Heights of
stimulation and in the middle band are
these activities that you were just
describing uh this middle band is where
we usually make our contribution it's
things that are less they release less
dopamine than other things in our life
but here lies writing here lies playing
an instrument here lies having coffee
with a friend and resisting the the urge
to rise to a new height of mental
stimulation by checking your phone
staying in that band beneath that are
the most calming activities that we can
tend to do throughout the day you know
towards the bottom are you know just
lying on the couch and letting your mind
wander might be at the very bottom
watching a campfire
yeah just watching the Flames dance and
kind of letting the conversation that's
happening fade in and out at the same
time nature right hiking through nature
might be towards the bottom but
different bands on this chart of mental
stimulation we can actually draw a chart
of our own and I highly recommend doing
so charting the activities that you tend
to throughout the day to get a feel of
what your average stimulation height is
and get a feel for the ways that the
different activities you tend to
throughout the day make you feel
generally speaking we want to lower our
mental stimulation height because that
is what leads us to make a bigger
contribution that is what leads us to
also find that balance of productivity
but also calm and also enjoyment and
also accomplishment and also optimizing
the contribution
of our work but also how our work makes
us feel that is the ideal band and it's
the most productive it happens to be the
most productive band as well
instead of rising to these Heights of
stimulation that are difficult to come
down from we find this enjoyment and
this presence and this deep connection
with whatever it is that we're doing
that's the place we want to be so
thinking it you know maybe not
necessarily in terms of laziness
um even though it's kind of a lazy way
to spend time to be at a high altitude
it's it's kind of leaning on distraction
and Technology to do our thinking for us
and presenting the most dopaminergic
morsels of content to us it takes a bit
of work to be further down in that
imaginary chart but that's where the
benefits are what if someone feels
guilty when they're relaxing
oh who doesn't
you know it's such a such a big part of
that relaxation guilt comes from the
fact that we are terrible at measuring
our productivity uh and so we feel
guilty when we're not making progress
towards something you know because we
value progress so much and maybe more so
because the world around us values
progress to such an extreme level
we feel a disconnect with our behavior
and those cultural values but I would
make the argument that there there is
immense productivity to be found in
relaxation so you know one simple
example we talked about scatter focus
last time that that mental uh mind
wandering mode of our mind but if you're
a leader or if you're a Creator or if
you're in a position where your thoughts
can lead to you making a difference or
you generating an idea can lead to
making a difference there is pride to be
found in this relaxation and letting our
mind come down to a new lower level of
mental stimulation so going on a walk is
a simple example of this if you're a CEO
of a Fortune 500 company and you know
you have a meeting and you blow it off
to take a walk in the in the park around
your campus
that walk
might lead you to an Insight that turns
your company from a a 100 billion dollar
company into a one trillion dollar
company
one walk
right that's the power that's the value
of an idea you look at you know say Bob
Iger or somebody walking around at Steve
Jobs walking around it Tim Cook who I I
probably actually did this it turned
Apple into a trillion dollar company you
know if you look at Tim Cook taking a
walk a stroll around the Apple campus
you think oh man what is he slacking off
he's not even listening to anything on
his phone you know he's not listening to
a podcast he's not using that time to
get ahead and this goes back to how we
often are terrible at measuring our
productivity we often look to busyness
as a proxy measure for how productive we
are even though busyness is really no
different from an active form of
laziness when we don't leave when it
doesn't lead us to accomplish anything
of importance like when we're at that
high altitude of stimulation but
when we look to how much we actually
accomplish
when we look to the results that we
generate for how we spend our time it
can be profound so the ironic thing
about investing in calm and overcoming
Anxiety is a big part of me feels less
productive now than than I used to but
when I look at my accomplishments list
at the end of the week which I keep
every week and you know to kind of
maintain the con you know measurements
of the contributions I make each each
and every week I contribute far more
right now with a calm mind and with a
mind that wanders and generates ideas
then I did in you know a whole month of
directionless hustle a lot of the time
and this goes to that acquisition
mentality that idea of this mindset of
more
goals without endpoints
are useless
right we so often have this striving
that we just settle into by default that
doesn't lead us to contribute anything
but when we measure our actual
contributions that's when we realize
just how productive we are
sorry I feel like I went out for like 10
minutes there but I got worked up
talking about this not at all I feel it
feels a little bit to me like what
people are optimizing for is a sense of
hustle it's like they're actually
chasing the hustle itself as opposed to
the outcomes that the hustle is supposed
to achieve yeah this is what would
appear to be one of the fundamental
differences that you have discovered I'm
not supposed to be
pursuing the degree of difficulty or
pain or sacrifice or effort that I go
through I'm bothered about the outcomes
on the other side of it that's what I'm
optimizing for exactly and we so often
look to the measures that you just
mentioned you know we look at how
exhausted we are at the end of the day
and think oh I'm so exhausted I must be
productive beware as a badge of honor as
well right exactly yeah we we have this
Pride that comes from busyness I know a
lot of busy people who don't accomplish
a single damn thing every day
um I know a lot of lazy people who make
more of a contribution than than either
of us do right it it comes back to
deliberateness I think at the end of the
day uh the most productive people that
they don't work more frantically and
faster and with this direction you know
a goal without an end point is just a
fantasy
um they work with a calm deliberateness
on what is truly important and what they
lack in speed they make up for in
intentionality and ultimately I think
that's what it comes down to at the end
of the day our intent or our level of
deliberateness and intentionality is the
factor in speaking of optimization
that's the factor we need to optimize
for we need to optimize for intention
because the more we do so the more we
accomplish what we set out to do that
should be the ultimate measure of
productivity did you do what you set out
to do whether you were taking in a beach
putting your feet up drinking a couple
pina coladas or whether you were
clearing out the Thousand emails that
were building up in your inbox and you
know bringing somebody new onto your
team and re finishing a book that you've
had on the go for quite some time you
know it comes back to our intentions
that's where productivity begins uh and
ends in my opinion
when it comes down to the strategies
that you did in order to be able to find
how to become more calm in life well
were there anything that is common held
calm wisdom but that you tried and found
that it was rubbish didn't work for you
and or there was no evidence in the
literature to suggest that it's even
beneficial oh that's a fascinating
question
um I would say a lot of the self-care
strategies out there uh the whole idea
of self-care was one area that it
surprised me just how much there was to
Wade through uh in that area and there
are definite benefits to yoga and meta I
I've been meditating for half an hour a
day for well over a decade at this point
but yet somehow I still burnt out and
still fell into this pit of anxiety
and it just goes to show that a lot of
the self-care strategies out there meta
meditation most definitely works better
than others most of the so many
self-care strategies are just a Band-Aid
solution you know if you fundamentally
hate your job meditation is not going to
help you you know it might help you uh
you know cope but it won't fix that
underlying issue if you're in a in an
abusive relationship for an example that
there or you have one of those in your
life with somebody who's close or
distant to you
you need to pull these problems out by
the root in order for them to stop
providing you with chronic stress that
might lead you to a point of burnout or
anxiety and I think that you know it
more than anything else
when I look at what allowed me to
actually welcome more calm into my life
and move from that point of high anxiety
down to that state of high calmness it
wasn't these like simple tactics it was
really deconstructing my days and I
think that's what we have to do we don't
have to deconstruct our lives you don't
have to go as deep as your values though
that most definitely helps to have kind
of a a reflection in that direction
because our mind we tend to optimize any
currency we come into contact with
whether that be money status follower
count whatever and that definitely
includes a lot of the currencies we come
into contact with in our in our modern
culture that by default we want more of
without really thinking of why and so
having that values connection is
immensely helpful but we need to go
deeper you know how much dopamine do you
get throughout the day how much of your
behavior is structured on top of
dopamine whether that be in the pursuit
of acquiring more or in the pursuit of
finding more mental stimulation so you
can continue to fly at such a height
that was an uncomfortable truth that I
had to face in my own life is so much of
my day was structured around dopamine
and because of that I never felt
satisfied or present what were you doing
what like what were the things you were
doing that was chasing dopamine yeah it
was just tending to distraction
throughout the day but you know I was
pretty good at resisting distraction
when I was on the clock and working but
when I was off the clock the easiest way
to entertain my mind I would just turn
on YouTube and receive all these
dopamine hits
um you know it was alcohol use it was
take out use it was attending to a lot
of super stimuli in the form of social
media and checking on things that fed my
ego a lot of the time just checking how
many books were selling on a given week
and I say week but I would check it
multiple times a day how are the books
ranked today just to get that that
validation boost and
we need to go beyond the quick fixes to
ask these these questions and uproot a
lot of this this chronic stress in our
life and so I think one shift that
occurred uh with how I think about
anxiety is the surface level uh
advice that doesn't go deep enough I
don't know if that makes sense but I
think we need to go deep in order to
find calm I like the analogy of you not
being able to meditate your way out of a
bad job yeah there is a fundamental
issue and some of the symptoms of that
problem can be dealt with you're going
to give yourself more mindfulness maybe
it'll help you be at peace with your
dick of a boss or whoever it is you're
dealing with yeah but you're still in a
[ __ ] job you know you're still in a job
that you don't enjoy okay so I think a
lot of people are probably in a position
very similar to the one that you just
described which is a very
dopaminergically driven permanently
chasing distraction probably when
they're on the clock as well as off the
clock yeah
um
what have you done dopamine is one hell
of a drug what have you done to be able
to down regulate how much you're chasing
for it why are you not looking at the
books sold or the news articles or the
Instagram likes why are you no longer
looking at that or what were the
strategies that allowed you to down
regulate that well uh stimulation
fasting you know I found is something I
resisted doing for the longest time uh
often called a dopamine fast and I had
heard dopamine fast you know mention
again and again and I never really
applied it to my own life but I thought
okay I'm on this this experiment for
calm let me try this and so for a month
I cut out social media I cut out email
on my phone cut out all the all the
stuff that exists at a high height of
stimulation and I I found that the first
week or so it was quite Restless it does
take our mind time to adjust downward
into a new lower level of mental
stimulation but the benefits of doing so
are absolutely perfect and I noticed
this in the most simple ways so for an
example I would often tend to just a
quick social media check or a quick
scroll around on my phone between things
so if a meeting ended at 2 55 and the
next meeting was at three instead of
thinking about the meeting I would
scroll for five minutes uh you know
these distractions kind of filling the
gaps of our day like water what if my
friends calls that a holding pattern
activity
so I like that when you're currently
just waiting you're circling the airport
something's about to happen and one of
his this is three years ago on the lifx
episode and he said everyone's got a
holding pattern activity and what you
want to do is try and make the activity
that you use in your holding pattern
something that you would want you to do
so yeah what he did was he bought a
Kindle and he put that on his desk and
he kept his phone outside of his desk so
if he was in between calls if he was
going to do something he would pick up
his Kindle or he would maybe he had some
other stuff that he was playing about
with on his desk my point being that
um there's two levels to this I suppose
one would be substitute what you're
doing for something which is better but
another layer deeper than that would be
substitute the chasing of wanting a
something for realizing that you don't
need to chase anything and just allow
yourself to be
yeah yeah and with the constraints of
the experiment I noticed that happening
automatically uh so when I couldn't tend
to something I I noticed that I was just
managing the receipts on my desk which
had been sitting there for months this
stuff happens automatically uh in an
evening without going on YouTube uh
because I wasn't allowed it deleted the
app off the Apple TV
um I would just scroll around photos and
reminisce about old memories and I think
you hit the nail right on the head uh we
need to substitute activities in for
these old activities so there isn't some
hole in our life that just we have to
awkwardly try to fill with things in the
moment so ones that allow us to feel
connected with others and this sense of
Pride I took up piano lessons at the
time my piano is just on the left here
you can see in the video nice and uh and
so now I have something to do when the
call ends a bit early you know at this
lower level of mental stimulation
and you know we a dopamine fast for
about a month it's a pain but it works
incredibly incredibly well what's the
effect
it the effect is we no longer crave
novelty
nearly as much you know novelty doesn't
drive what we do
and because of that
our mind settles down finally you know
we finally settle down into a new lower
level of mental stimulation where the
calm things are we allow
intentions to inform in our mind and to
inform our actions and so instead of
just kind of you know
frantically moving between objects of
attention uh choosing whatever option in
the moment happens to be the most novel
uh Because We crave dopamine in the
moment more than almost anything else we
have that pause before we act and we
allow an intention to form in our mind
that okay maybe I should just organize
these receipts or maybe oh I have 10
minutes not five because they're going
to be late maybe I should just practice
this piece on the piano and we take
control of our Behavior significantly
more when we're at that lower level
another
example activity that I found remarkably
well I mentioned how the networks for
presence and for acquisition are
anti-correlated with one another is that
science of savoring that I mentioned so
having a saver list which is just a list
of everything you love to enjoy here's
the fascinating thing one of my favorite
questions and everybody should try this
uh to ask somebody who is really driven
uh in this acquisition mentality one of
my favorite things to ask them is what
do you Savor the most in your life and
this stumps pretty much all of the most
driven people that I've asked this to
and the research shows that this idea of
savoring wherein we convert positive
experiences into positive emotions
men find it more challenging to do than
women and wealthier people find it more
challenging to do than people who are
not wealthy because of that acquisition
mentality
but having this list of things that we
Savor is is a beautiful way of
practicing presence each and every day
it can be as simple as a cup of tea it
can be a time with your partner it can
be a good book it can be a fireplace
that have you happen to have in the
house it can be an instrument you left
something you love an album that you
love
um to listen to whatever it is you love
to save or make a list and deliberately
practice this skill of savoring indeed
it is a skill but what you're really
practicing is not only uh optimizing the
enjoyment you get out of everyday
experiences but you're actually optim
and practicing this skill of switching
over this acquisition Network to This
Here and Now Network and the more Nimble
nimbly you can switch between these two
modes the the easier you will find it to
be focused and present on whatever it is
that you intend to be doing and so this
mental nimbleness that comes from the
skill of savoring indeed it is a skill
we can even Savor the past and the
future we can Savor the past by
practicing it's called reminiscence
we've all heard the word but we just
relive in a positive experience that
happened in our past in our mind and
visualize it just for a few minutes
savoring we can also Savor the future
and this hap it counts as savoring
because we do it in the present we Savor
the future it's called anticipation and
we can do this by counting down the days
to an event we can do this by you know
just talking about something some
experience that's coming up but the
research shows that counting down even
just counting down the days to an event
creates effective memory traces in our
mind kind of a path through a force that
we walk over again which leads us to
enjoy the experience even more when it
actually does happen which it lets us
extract more meaning and enjoyment out
of our time so dopamine fasting savoring
just a couple strategies to different
effects right lowering the stimulation
level and being able to switch between
the acquisition mentality and the uh the
present here and now mentality all the
some components of savoring individual
skills that contribute to being
effective at the overall job of savoring
yeah well there are it's kind of sub
components to Savory uh so luxuriating
is one of these so think of a cat you
know so I I just gotta get cats are on
my mind we just got a kitten a few uh
weeks ago her name is Eleanor think of
think of a cat soaking in the sun
luxuriating in the sun that's one way we
can Savor an experience uh gratitude
counts as savoring as well so the
practice of Thanksgiving recalling three
things that we're grateful for each and
every day this is this is a ritual my
wife and I uh have developed every night
when we're going to sleep before we kind
of fall asleep we recall three things
that we're grateful for and people ask
like do you run out of things and it's
like hell no no we we could probably
list 10 each and every day
um marveling is yet another uh thing so
when we feel a sense of ah by something
uh whether that's kind of even just
looking at the window and marveling at
the snow uh it could be and that
actually by the way when we uh see
through our whole eyes including our
peripheral vision that has a bonus
calming effect when when we feel a sense
of awe with something that's visual but
yeah just you know whether it's
luxuriating Thanksgiving marveling uh
anticipation uh reminiscence or just uh
mindfully enjoying something in the
moment these all these all count
thankfully
all right Kristoff I appreciate you very
much thank you for coming on where
should people go if they want to keep up
to date with all the stuff that you do
yes sir thank you for having me on again
the book is called how to calm your mind
uh finding presence and productivity in
anxious times I think it's the best
thing I have ever written and I hope you
find the same it's wherever books are
sold uh I am at Chris bailey.com
and my podcast that I do with my wife is
called time and attention bonus plug
there but yeah the book The main thing
thank you so much man all right Chris
thank you what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
face
[Music]